kubernetes is a platform for managing
your containers machine learning
workflows can often get really messy
especially in production so it was only
a matter of time before somebody put the
two together how do we do machine
learning on kubernetes without too much
extra work stay tuned to find out
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng guo
and on this episode we're going to check
out cube flow an open-source project to
help make running machine learning
training and prediction on kubernetes
clusters easier the cube flow project is
dedicated to making deployments of
machine learning workflows on kubernetes
simple portable and scalable more
specifically it wants to allow you to
easily deploy your code to all sorts of
environments from say your laptop to a
desktop with two GPUs or say a training
kubernetes cluster versus a production
cluster and of course this wouldn't be
kubernetes if it didn't allow you to
scale everything with demand cube flow
began life as a way to open-source
tensorflow extended or tf-x which was
how tensorflow is run internally at
Google while it was originally just a
simpler way to run tensorflow jobs on
kubernetes it has since expanded to
become a multi architecture multi-cloud
framework for running entire machine
learning pipelines with many
contributors all across the ecosystem
this might be a good time for a little
confession I myself I don't know a whole
lot about kubernetes having spent the
past several years focus on tensorflow
and data science and machine learning
my kubernetes skills are well they're
not exactly top notch so I'm really
hoping that cube flow can allow me to
deploy test flow and other machine
workloads on to kubernetes successfully
because I do here Cooper Nettie's is
pretty great so let's see what it looks
like to use coop flow shall we cube flow
aims to be able to run anywhere
kubernetes can
this means everything from your laptop
to bare-metal servers all the way to the
public cloud for now let's check out how
this works on google kubernetes engine
or gke installing cute flows to gke is
actually shockingly simple since there's
a click to deploy user interface all I
had to do was enter the project ID of my
cloud project give my deployment name
and choose his own to put it in then all
the necessary resources were provisioned
automatically now that is my kind of
deployment so with queue flow installed
and the UI accessible you're ready to
dive into the world of cube flow you can
train models visualize them with tensor
board surf models build pipelines and
login to Jupiter hub to manage all these
things most of the time we get to use
the very same training code that we
would be running locally anyway and just
add some configuration files for the
cube flow specific parts and then you
can run them in coop flow with no code
changes I can perform training on my
kubernetes cluster using cube flow and
have the exported model either stay on
disk in the kubernetes cluster or send
it off to a google cloud storage bucket
allowing me to easily share or deploy
the train model to systems outside of
the cluster all right that's enough of
me talking if you are interested in
running machine learning pipelines on
kubernetes then it's time for you to get
started on cube flow I've linked to a
number of code labs and resources in the
description down below to help you get
started thanks for watching this episode
of cloud AI adventures and if you
enjoyed it be sure to hit that like
button and subscribe to get all the
latest updates right when they come out
for now head down to the description
below for more information about how to
get cube flow up and running on your
kubernetes cluster
[Music]
[Music]